hey everybody its charlie you may have
just seen the game of thrones finished
filming the longest battle in the show's
history for a single episode and it's
twice as long as the next longest one
which was battle of the bastards there's
also a whole bunch of news about what's
going on during convention season
between Khan of Thrones and Comic Con
later this summer so I'll explain that
at the end of the video but this huge
battle that they've been hyping up in
the news the past week has been filming
on two particular sets for the past 55
days twice as long to film as the next
biggest battle in show's history so
let's break this down and if you're
finding me for the first time I am doing
a DVD giveaway all you have to do to
enter that just be a subscriber and
leave a comment on the video they've
also been a lot of reports about the way
that they upgrade the prosthetics and
the special effects that they do for
these big practical battles so like a
lot of it is CG they have a big green
screen set that I'll talk about but a
really good example the evolution of the
way they do this is back during season 6
where they'd already gotten pretty crazy
and you have episodes like the door
where you have the Nike and the army of
the Dead penetrating the three-eyed
Ravens tree so you have actors in there
white Walker makeup and you have a lot
of whites for the brief is for the
carrot so we have to be practical about
things
the artist is gonna be able to wear this
stuff day in day out it's not too heavy
now we have the naked on Vissarion in
just the sheer size of the army of the
Dead like the number of whites has
increased dramatically especially by the
time we get to these season 8 battles
which largely like this one that I'm
talking about is taking place mostly at
Winterfell I believe it'll be episode 3
and obviously it'll be a Miguel subhanak
episode because that's what he's doing
during a season 8 directing their really
big battle episodes but you can kind of
see how big the army is at the end of
season 7 as they breach the wall imagine
they snake down through the new gift
past the last hearth the car hold the
dreadfort coincidentally all the banners
that cited against House Stark in the
Second Battle of Winterfell so I guess
we could call this season 8 Battle of
Winterfell the third Battle of
Winterfell technically but a lot of
people reported seeing whites riding on
horses which is sort of a big upgrade
like their super version of a white
because you go from like the Ray
Harryhausen looking whites at the end of
season 4 like
pure skeletons to the whites during
season seven in that beyond the wall
episode that actually looked like
they've gotten smarter because you see
the hell throw that rock and you see the
white look at it consider it for a
moment and realize that the ice isn't
breaking
pop you could argue that that's the
night Kings consciousness that's
actually just seeing so it's really the
night king just seeing that through
their eyes and then telling them to move
forward well what I think is more likely
that they just made a creative choice
behind the scenes because they really
have changed the rules for how whites
work on the show in the past eight
seasons like in the way that some TV
shows and movies treat zombies
differently are they George Romero
zombies are they Walking Dead zombies
just like mindless creatures are they
smart zombies that run like the Zack
Snyder version I guess you could justify
whites riding horses because their
forces will be so much larger by the
time they get down to Winterfell like
you just have to imagine that anything
that's alive is gonna be added to the
army of the Dead so there'll be more
animals we don't know if we're gonna
have another polar bear situation
because that felt like something that
they had to do by itself like you
couldn't do polar bear in the middle of
this big battle here it would just be
way too much for them to handle from a
production standpoint because the Battle
of the lake here was mostly about
incorporating the dragons into the fight
against the white walkers which is
really what's gonna be happening at this
Battle of Winterfell because you have
both the Daenerys dragons and Viserion
for the first time so you see the need
for this giant green screen set so all
the more important that the Sirian
breathe blue fire because this will all
be happening in the dark that's been one
of the complaints about Game of Thrones
the last couple of seasons is that for
all the really amazing things they do
some of the episodes that they film at
night are pitch black so if you don't
have a really good TV that's calibrated
well sometimes you have to scoot up
right to the screen to see what's going
on in the background even if they don't
release like a full blown trailer at
Comic Con this summer I would bet that
they release a special effects reel just
giving you an idea for the scope of how
they're filming these big things they've
kind of done that the last couple of
seasons they've always released a lot of
behind the scenes stuff but as the
battles have gotten bigger season to
season also the ratings have gotten
bigger - bigger they've hyped that more
and more so they wind up fast-tracking a
lot of that footage especially because
they could just show you the behind the
scenes stuff without it having to go
through months and months of
post-production which is part of the
reason for the increased delay this year
like they could wind up with a Justice
League situation if they don't give
themselves enough time to finish the
proper CG sort of going down the list of
the biggest battles on the show
battle of the bastards 25 days long
hardhome was about 15 days dan and Dave
say that Blackwater was 30 days of night
shoots back during season two mostly
because it was all at night and you have
fewer night hours to film than you would
during the day which is why even though
Battle of the pastures is much bigger
it didn't take quite as long to film and
like I said the really cool thing about
this big 55 night long shoot that they
just got done filming is only for a
single episode it does not include the
big battle that they'll eventually film
on their King's Landing set which even
though it might be their final big
battle sounds like it won't be quite as
big within the actual episode as this
episode 3 Battle of Winterfell this
doesn't really tell us anything about
who dies during these big battles I know
there's a lot of speculation about them
shedding characters I would expect that
if they're going to be killing off
secondaries smaller characters most of
that will happen during their Episode
three battle then most of the mains will
survive to this final big battle at the
King's Landing set but like I said they
have a sort of filming that yet they
will be filming episodes all the way up
to June and then the rest of the year is
basically them finishing post-production
so that is why we will probably start
getting footage at Comic Con but I'm
only expecting behind the scenes if I'm
not expecting any completed trailers but
I have a feeling that HBO's marketing
department in the game of thrones
producers are cherry-picking footage so
just expect it to start rolling out
during the summer because this will
probably be their longest promotional
campaign that they've ever done just
remember how they hyped up season 7 it
took a little longer to start getting
footage from that but in total they
dropped way more footage than they did
before previous seasons
[Music]
so no worries there and I don't think I
mentioned it before but HBO did confirm
that they would be spending more money
per episode producing the prequel series
when we eventually get to that than they
did on the main series so if you think
season 6 through season 8 of Game of
Thrones is really big just imagine the
prequel series being even bigger the
first real big convention of the season
though is gonna be Khan of Thrones
that's gonna be at the end of May
in right now their guest list is Gendry
Gilly Shae Lysa Arryn junior Mormon
Syrio Forel
Ross young Hodor is coming back he was
at Cana Thrones last season and they had
Ramsay Bolton last season too so they'll
probably be expanding their guest list
as we get closer if you haven't gone in
the past Cana Thrones is just a game of
Thrones specific convention the Watchers
and the wall people are involved there's
a lot of familiar faces from the Game of
Thrones community usually that's where
you get a lot of behind-the-scenes
details HBO doesn't have a real big
presence there they save most of their
stuff for a comic-con in San Diego which
will be later in July believe all your
requests for bonus videos in the
comments below and I'll say
congratulations to the latest giveaway
winner Gemini's star please private
message me on the back end of my channel
so I can get your contact details click
here for my Gendry Aria video and click
here for brand new Avengers infinity war
thank you so much for watching everybody
stay awesome I'll see you guys tonight